photographies peintures lumière et
nouvelles technologies et es est un clin
d'oeil à l'écriture inclusive
une exposition en partenariat avec une
association d'étudiante et ria qui
soutient les arts numériques et les
artistes émergents de c'était d'avoir un
passe dans un espèce de petit panel de
différents types d'expression dans l'art
numérique ça c'est une chose et aussi la
pertinence de la réponse
enfin c'est pas la pertinence mais en
tout cas la façon de répondre à la
question
l'oeuvre enfin le genre un futile la
création de l'oeuvre ou la réception
un appel à candidature a été lancé six
installations qui interroge sur le genre
ont été sélectionnés des oeuvres qui
pousse à la réflexion
[Musique]
parmi elles cette création permanente de
caspar ravel
c'est une oeuvre qui est créé par une
intelligence artificielle en direct donc
ses pertes romatif sait jamais la même
chose
elle elle joue et donc elle compose en
direct tout le temps vous avez la même
chose et pareil elle complète l'image
avec du glitch charton que c'est l'art
du bug informatique
une exposition qui incitent à la
discussion entre les visiteurs et qui
est visible jusqu'au 8 mars à la
commanderie ya elancourt